we love to take phone calls 617 830 for
750 is the number that is the only
number to call to get on live with us we
have our next caller who's on the line
and tell us where you're calling from
also hello David um air coming from uh
stormy Tampa Florida all right what can
we do for you today well David I just
want to say I enjoy the show I'm gonna
miss Lois and I wishing all the best of
luck I hope you move south I wake of a
storm goes away but uh I love to show on
YouTube and I would just like to see you
guys add a segment like I'm doing on
location do outside of that gum studio I
know you're moving to Boston or whatever
but um maybe do some outside shoot stuff
you know we'll listen there's sort of
two ways in which we will be coming to
you from outside the studio in the
future number one is I will be uh
broadcasting from a variety of locations
throughout the rest of the year we're
going to do sort of a test of the mobile
setup on in early October we'll have
more news about that it won't be hugely
exciting but it'll be sort of like a
proof of concept I will be coming to you
from a couple of different spots
throughout the fall now that's just the
regular show but just I'll be in a
different spot we are also talking with
new producer Jason Shepherd about doing
some of many documentaries on location
we have a few ideas already in the works
uh there's that there's a number of
ideas Jason that are sort of in the
ether right now that I think might um
please this collar yeah there's a lot
going around very good hold on one sec
adjacent fill up those I say there's a
lot going around Boston we are a hub of
technology and of social revolution and
I think you'll see some some great
pieces on location yep great idea and
will you know we'll have more info for
you about it as we have it all right
Dave I'll let you know if I'm here after
this hurricane passes I've got my
glasses on in case we flood out over
your buddy all right stay safe thank you
and uh we will we will hopefully talk to
you again gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low use price there's never any due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / TDPS the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support our
show by going to gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s